hey folks thanks to mainstream media  many of you may not know what's going on  with the current administration which is  why this week I decided to do something  different and put the first two months  of Obama's presidency into a song okay  Gitmo closing maybe not Alma's having  second thoughts  cabinets taxes mega bonus AIG  trillion-dollar stimulus fighting  getting restless he still kept in his  game ever getting on stage  government cuts bonus  pregnancies abortion bar business  tornado state policies our stuffing or  maybe I don't freaking dope it over  [ __ ] if you wanna  crazy stop it was a speak and once you  honking your abortion barn man not on my  channel  but that's America now I can fix Obama  alienating funding guns looks like now I  have a show  Obama goes on late night with that  bumper water making fun of someone  keeping an eye on the enemies this guy  is gonna be our VP  ah our country is going to hell in a  handbasket